PROFESSOR: All right, an
announcement that I must make,
after developing all these
friendships and working
together, we will, next Tuesday,
once again, enter a
brief adversarial
relationship.
And we will have quiz
number two.
What we will cover on that
quiz will be about 50%,
perhaps a little bit
more, on symmetry.
And I'll remind you in just a
minute what we've covered
since the last quiz.
And the second half or 40% of
the quiz will be on the
formalism of tensors and
tensor manipulation.
And obviously, you've
had a chance only to
do a very few problems.
So these will be pretty basic
questions and nothing tricky
or very difficult.
So let me remind you very, very
quickly just by topics
what we've covered.
We began the period following
the first quiz discussing how
we can take the plane groups,
two-dimensional symmetries
that are translationally
periodic, and defining a third
translation to stack up the
plane groups to give us a
three-dimensional periodic
arrangement of symmetry elements.
In doing so, we found that
we had to pick that third
translation such that the
symmetry elements that were in
the plane group, and those were
the things that made the
lattices of the plane groups
special, made them square or
hexagonal or rectangular, that
was true because there was
symmetry there.
Once again, symmetry and the
specialness of a lattice are
two inseparable parts
of the story.
But if we did this,
the symmetry
elements had to coincide.
Otherwise, we would reproduce
new symmetry elements in the
base of the cell and
wreck everything.
So when we did that, there were
a very limited number of
ways of doing it.
In the course of doing that,
we fell headlong over screw
axis in the same way that we
fell over glide planes as soon
as we put mirror lines in a
two-dimensional lattice.
The interesting thing was that
that exercise of stacking the
two-dimensional plane groups
gave us almost all of the
lattice types that exist
in three dimensions.
And the reason for that is we
showed very directly that
inversion requires nothing.
So therefore, any of the point
groups that were used in
deriving the plane groups, when
augmented by inversion to
give a three-dimensional point
group, are going to require
nothing more than the lattices
that we derived by stacking
the plane groups.
And that took care of just about
everything except for
the cubic symmetries.
And we disposed of those
in very short order.
So that led us to the
14 space lattices,
so-called bravais lattices.
And then we proceeded to work
with those lattices and put in
the point groups that could
accommodate them.
Having discovered glide planes,
we then, if we had
done the process systematically,
would have
replaced mirror planes
by glide planes.
And having discovered screw
axes, we replace pure rotation
by screw axis rotations.
And then doing what we did but
didn't have to do very often,
mercifully, for the plane
groups, we said one could also
interweave symmetry elements.
And that gave a few additional
space groups.
We did not derive very
many of them.
What is important at this stage
is simply to realize
that their properties and
applications are very similar
to what we discovered for the
two-dimensional plane groups.
The notation is a little
bit different.
Because there can be symmetry
elements parallel to the plane
of the paper so that in
depicting the arrangement of
symmetry elements you need a
little [? chevron-type ?]
device to indicate whether
you've got a mirror plane or a
glide plane in the
base of the cell.
And similarly with two-fold
axes, and that's about the
only thing that would be in the
plane of the paper if the
principal symmetry is normal to
the paper, we need a device
for indicating the elevation
and whether the axis is a
two-fold rotation
axis or a screw.
So there's a geometrical
language for describing the
arrangement of the
space groups.
We had a few problems in
determining space group
symbols and interpreting
what these mean.
But again, I don't think I would
be sadistic enough to
ask you to derive a complicated
three-dimensional
space group.
I don't know.
Maybe over the weekend, if I get
to feeling mean, I might
ask you something in
those directions.
But it will not be anything
terribly formidable.
Then finally, we looked at the
way in which space groups can
be used to describe
three-dimensional periodic
arrays of atoms.
And that again was strictly
analogous to what we did in
two dimensions.
The description of the
three-dimensional arrangement
of atoms, particularly if it
is too complicated to be
readily appreciated in a
projection, would have to be
given in terms of the space
group, the type of position
that is occupied, either
special or the general
position, and then depending on
how many degrees of freedom
are available in those positions
to give you the
coordinates of the element or
just the x-coordinate or the x
and y-coordinate.
And then you run to the
international tables.
You don't have to work
this out yourself.
And you find the list of
coordinates that are related
by symmetry for that particular
special position
and then plug in x and y to get
all the coordinates of the
atoms in the unit cell.
To go to the practical aspects
of this, usually only simple
structures can be projected
with any clarity that lets
them be interpreted.
And even with a computer these
days one can show an
orthographic projection of the
structure and then in real
time manipulate it so you
can see this beautiful
construction with colored
shiny spheres
in it rotating around.
But if it's a complicated
structure, even that doesn't
do you very much.
It works for NaCO and
zinc sulfide.
But you know what
those look like.
And so you don't really need
this very attractive, real
time interaction.
What I found works well is to
take the structure and slice
it apart in layers like a
layer cake and look at a
limited range of the one
translation, generally, one of
the shorter translations, and
examine the coordination of
atoms within that layer.
And so by slicing the structure
away and looking at
it in several layers that are
stacked on top of one another,
the way I work between the ears,
usually lets me gain an
appreciation of what's going
on in that structure.
Something different might
work for you.
Matter of fact, you might be a
gifted person who can see the
things spinning around on a
computer screen and understand
exactly what it is.
But everybody's mind works in
a slightly different way.
OK, that is roughly what we'll
be covering on symmetry.
Then we got into the connection
between symmetry
and physical properties.
And we defined what we
meant by a tensor.
A tensor of the second
rank is something
that relates to vectors.
We got into a notation involving
the assumption that
any repeated subscript, and
there's subscripts all over
the place in tensor
properties.
Any repeated subscript is
automatically implied to be
summed over from 1 to 3.
We then derived the laws for
transformation of a tensor.
Namely that, if you specify
the change of coordinate
system by a direction cosine
scheme, cij, where cij is the
cosine of the angle between x of
i prime and x sub j, that,
since these direction cosines
constitute unit vectors, there
had to be relations
between them.
Namely the sum of the squares
of the terms in any row or
column had to be unity.
The sum of corresponding terms
in any row or column
had to add to 0.
Because these represented dot
products of unit vectors in a
Cartesian coordinate system.
And then using this array of
direction cosines, we found
that the way in which a second
ranked tensor transformed was
that each tensor element was
given by a linear combination
of all of the elements of
the original tensor.
And out in front of the tensor
was a product of two direction
cosines, the subscripts of which
were determined by the
indices of that element.
A vector could be regarded
as a first ranked tensor.
And everybody understands
the law for
transformation of a vector.
Namely that each component
of the vector is a linear
combination of every component
of the original vector with
one direction cosine
out in front.
Tensor of second rank has a
product of two direction
cosines summed over all
the elements of
the original tensor.
Third ranked tensors, which,
believe it or not, we'll get
into after the quiz in
considerable detail, and even
shudder fourth ranked tensors
are going to involve
summations that involve scads of
terms and products of three
and four direction cosines
respectively.
So we won't get very
far into tensors.
We will perhaps have a couple of
questions on the nature of
anisotropy that's implied
by these relations.
And I think, if you looked at
the problem sets to this
point, that's as far as
we'll go on the quiz.
And we will not throw something
at you that you've
not seen before.
So it'll be merciful.
We'll pull out all the stops
in the last quiz.
Because then you'll
be leaving.
And you can hate me.
But I never have to deal
with you again.
So that will not make
any difference.
All right, I have handed back
all of the problem sets except
two, which are partly done.
I never again will ask anybody
to draw out patterns of
rotoinversion and rotoreflection
axes.
Because they go on
and on and on.
And I am so tired of staring at
little circles and trying
to tell which ones are right
and which one are wrong.
But that's something else
we have in common.
You probably hated looking at
them when you were drawing
them out for yourself.
So let me tell you what's going
to go on for the next
several days.
Tomorrow is a holiday, not for
instructors who are making up
a quiz, however.
So I will be in my office from
early morning on for the rest
of the day.
So if you want to come by to ask
questions, what I will be
doing primarily is finishing up
grading the problem sets.
And if you want to pick up your
problem sets and ask a
question about those, I am
there at your disposal
hopefully with no ringing phone
calls and no committee
meetings and nothing
of that sort.
If I have finished the problem
sets and you haven't gotten
yours yet, what I will do is
tape an envelope to my door
and have them tucked in there.
So you can come by any time over
the weekend and pick them
up if you want to get hold of
them and look them over at
your leisure.
I have to tell you, looking
ahead in the schedule, I,
unfortunately, bad timing, I
have to be away on Monday.
So if you have a last minute
question or you need to be
calmed down from a last minute
panic, you can catch me
Tuesday morning.
I'll be in all of the earlier
part of the day.
But if you do have questions,
please come in on Friday.
Because I'll have lots of
time to spend with you.
So your problem sets, anything
turned in to this point and
turned in today, should be on my
door, if you haven't called
for it no, later than the
beginning of the week.
OK, any questions?
Any puzzles that you want to go
over before we launch into
new material?
OK, what we have done with
second ranked tensor
properties is to derive a
whole set of symmetry
constraints on something aij
that represents a physical
property of a crystal.
And one of the things that
we've seen, let's look at
conductivity once more since
that's something we're all
familiar with and can readily
appreciate, that the
components of the current
density vector depend on all
of the components of the
applied electric field,
voltage per unit length.
And in as much as for anything
other than a crystal of cubic
symmetry, the numbers in this
array, at least some of them,
are different.
And that gives two surprising
results.
One is that the direction of
J relative to the applied
electric field will change
as you apply the field in
different directions
in the crystal.
And moreover, the magnitude of
the current is going to change
as you change the orientation
of field.
That's true of every crystal
in a crystal
system other than cubic.
So the thing that I would like
to address today is the
interesting matter of what is
the nature of this anisotropy
and if a consequence of a second
ranked tensor relation
is that, if we apply an electric
field, the current
doesn't go in the
same direction
as the applied field.
It runs off in some other
direction as non-intuitive as
that might seem.
First of all, there are
two directions.
If we talk about a property
varying with direction, which
direction are we talking about,
the direction of the
applied field, the direction of
the resulting current flux,
or something halfway in between,
split the difference?
Well, we can answer that
question by doing a couple of
thought experiments.
Suppose we had decided that we
want to measure the electrical
conductivity along the 1,
0, 0 direction of an
orthorhombic crystal.
What would we do?
Well, we get a hold
of that crystal.
And we would cut surfaces on
it such that this was the
direction of 1, 0, 0, if that's
what we wanted to do.
We would glom on electrodes and
put a voltage across this
crystal, this chunk of crystal
that we had cut out.
So when we say we're going to
measure the property along 1,
0, 0 or 1, 1, 1, what we really
mean is that we're
going to cut the crystal normal
to that direction and
then apply some sort of
electrodes or attach
some sort of probe.
So when we talk about the
direction of the property, the
direction of the property will
be the direction of the
applied vector.
And we had a very fancy name
for the applied vector.
We said we could think of that
as a generalized force.
And what happens is a
generalized displacement.
Notice that, when we apply the
field, there are all sorts of
components to J. And so the
direction of the property,
although we would get a number
out of this experiment, the
property really is a tensor.
And there are nine different
quantities involved in it.
OK, so the direction of the
property is going to be the
direction in which we apply
the generalized
force of the stimulus.
When we do that, however, that
is going to unequivocally, at
least in this experiment, place
the electric field in a
direction along the
crystallographic orientation
of interest.
Because the electric field in a
pair of electrodes like this
extends normal to those
electrodes.
The current flow, the charge per
unit area per unit time,
goes off in some direction
like this.
Well, conductivity relates
current flow to applied
electric field.
So would we say that the
conductivity, when we apply
field in that direction, is
simply J/E, magnitude of J
over magnitude of E since
these are both vectors
question mark?
The answer to that, if we do
this in terms of a thought
experiment, is no.
That is not what we're
measuring.
What we can imagine is that
between our electrodes is some
window of unit area between
those electrodes.
And what we're going to measure
as the current flow is
the amount of charge per unit
area per unit time that passes
between the electrodes, namely
the charge per unit area per
unit time that gets through this
window and reaches the
other electrode.
That's what we're going
to measure.
And what we're going to want
to call the conductivity is
the ratio of this part of the
current flux, let me call that
J parallel, over the magnitude
of E. And that's what we'll
mean by the conductivity in the
direction in which we've
applied the field.
The actual flow of
current goes off
in some other direction.
But what we measure, at least
in this experiment, is the
component of that charge flux
that goes through a window,
that pair of unit area, that's
parallel to the electrode.
And we don't really care if the
current is going off in a
different direction.
We don't even care if it jumps
around in majestic
loop-de-loops.
What we're going to measure is
the amount of that charge
motion that moves normal to our
window and gets through
one unit area from one
electrode to another.
So the conductivity and the
direction of E then is going
to be measured by the parallel
part of the resulting
generalized displacement divided
by the magnitude of
the applied generalized force.
If you're not convinced and
completely overwhelmed by
that, let me give you
another experiment.
Another tensor relation, another
tensor property, is
the diffusivity of a material.
And if you put a material in a
concentration gradient dc dx,
you produce a flux of matter.
And the proportionality constant
is the diffusion
coefficient.
And this has units of length
per unit time if you put in
the units of the concentration
gradient and the flux.
Well, dc dx is a gradient.
That's a vector really.
So a proper tensor relation,
instead of a scalar relation
like this, would be the change
of concentration with the i-th
coordinate.
And out in front would be a
diffusion coefficient Dij.
And this tensor relation would
give us the components of the
mass flux J1 J2 J3.
Actually, thermodynamically we
shouldn't be talking about a
concentration gradient.
We should be talking about a
gradient in free energy.
The concentration works
well enough.
And the concentration is
what one would measure.
So what might a typical
experiment be?
If you wanted to know what the
diffusion was in the 1, 1, 1
direction of some crystal, you
would, again, cut a plate that
is normal to the direction
of interest.
And then your boundary
conditions can be different.
But what you would typically do
for a simple experiment is
to put some sort of solute on
the surface of the crystal.
And what you would see after
heating the sample up for a
period of time is that the
material would have migrated
into the sample.
And if you plotted concentration
as a function of
distance along the normal to
the plate that you've cut,
this would do something
like that.
What can you say about this
process after you've done the
experiment?
All that you can say is that
some front of concentration
has advanced parallel
to the surface.
And you have no idea what the
individual atoms have done.
Then they could be doing
loop-de-loops
or little hip hops.
And all that you measure is
the rate at which material
advances in the direction
of the current gradient.
So again, I think I've convinced
you, hopefully, that
what you're measuring is the
flux of matter unit area per
unit time that is in the
direction of the applied
concentration gradient.
And you do not measure, and in
fact, in this instance, I
don't think I could come up
with even a very clever
experiment that would let you
measure in a single experiment
the magnitude and direction
of the net flux.
All right, so if we're measuring
a property then like
conductivity, the value of the
conductivity in the direction
of the applied field is going
to be the part of the
conductivity that is parallel
to the field divided by the
magnitude of the field.
We all agree on that.
Let's have a show of hands.
Fine.
I saw just a few tired hands
saying, OK, I believe, I
believe, let's get on with it.
All right, let me now put this
using our tensor relationship
into a nice analytic form that
we can not only do something
with but can gain
some insight.
The components of the charge
density vector are given by
the conductivity tensor sigma
1, 1 times the component of
the electric field E1 plus sigma
1, 2 times the component
of field E2 plus sigma
1, 3 times E3.
Or in general, I don't have to
write out every equation.
We can say that the i-th
component of J, our old friend
the second ranked tensor
property, again, is given by
sigma ij times each component
of applied field.
If we specify the direction
relative to the same
coordinate system in which the
electric field is being
applied, we can specify that
direction by a set of three
direction cosines,
l1, l2, and l3.
So we can write as the three
components of the electric
field E sub i as the magnitude
of E times the direction
cosines l1, l2, and l3.
So here we now have
the components of
the electric field.
If these are the components of
the electric field, we can say
that J sub i is going
to be equal to sigma
ij times E sub j.
And I can write for E sub j the
magnitude of E times the
direction cosines l sub j
where these are the same
direction cosines of
the applied field.
OK, now we have two relations in
reduced subscript form that
we can do something with.
The magnitude of the
conductivity in the direction
of E, that is in the direction
that has direction cosines li,
is going to be J parallel over
the magnitude of E. We can
write that as J.E, except that
involves the magnitude of J,
the magnitude of E times
the cosine of the
angle between them.
And so if I just want J
parallel, I'd want to divide
this by the magnitude of E. And
that will give me just the
part of J that falls parallel
to E. And then down here in
the denominator, I'll
have magnitude of E.
So if I tidy this up a little
bit to bring everything on the
same level, we can write the dot
product of J and E as Ji
Ei, like J1 E1 plus
J2 E2 plus J3 E3.
And then I will have
in the denominator
magnitude of E squared.
But we know what Ei is.
It's going to be magnitude
of E times li.
I know how to find the i-th
component of J. That's going
to be sigma ij times E sub j
over magnitude of E squared.
And I can write E sub j as
magnitude of E times l sub j
times l sub i times magnitude
of E divided by
magnitude of E squared.
Magnitude of E drops out.
Again, the conductivity
is linear the way
we've defined it.
It shouldn't depend on the
magnitude of E. And what I'm
left with then is a
very simple and a
rather profound relation.
It says that in a direction
specified by the set of
direction cosines l sub i that
the magnitude of conductivity
in that direction is going to
be li lj times sigma ij.
So that is an expression that
involves the three direction
cosines in which you're
applying the field and
measuring the property.
But this is a linear combination
of every one of
the elements in the
original tensor.
So if I write this out, because
this is an important
relation, it's going to be l1
squared sigma 1, 1 plus l2
squared sigma 2, 2 plus
l3 squared sigma 3, 3.
And then there will be
cross-terms of the form 2 l1
l2 sigma 1, 2 plus 2 l2 l3 times
sigma 2, 3 plus 2 l3 l1
times sigma 1, 3.
That has made an assumption.
And probably I should not have
done it at this point.
That's assuming that the term l1
l2 sigma 1, 2 and the term
l2 l1 sigma 2, 1 can
be lumped together.
And maybe I shouldn't
write it that way.
Because that assumes that
the tensor is symmetric.
And it doesn't have to be
for some properties.
So let me back off and write
it without any assumptions.
So this would be sigma 1, 2 l1
l2 plus sigma 1, 3 l1 l3 plus
sigma 2, 1 times l2 l1 and then
corresponding terms--
let me put this one
down here--
sigma 2, 1 times l2 l1 plus
sigma 3, 1 l3 l1.
And then the one that I'm
missing is sigma 2, 3 times l2
l3 plus sigma 3,
2 times l2 l3.
So there is an explicit
statement of this more compact
expression written in reduced
subscript notation.
OK, so this is something that is
going to tell us in a very
neat sort of way what the
anisotropy of the property is.
You pick the direction in
which you're interested.
And this will tell you the value
of the property in that
direction and, therefore, by
inference how things will
change with direction.
Let me quickly, and then I'll
pause to see if you have any
questions, give you an
interpretation of the meaning
of some of these elements
of the tensor.
We've really not been
able to do that.
We've been able to use them to
give the value of the property
in a given direction but not
their individual meaning.
Suppose I ask what the value of
the property would be along
the x1 direction.
So suppose we ask what value of
the conductivity would we
measure along x1 for a given
tensor sigma ij.
If that is the case,
l1 is equal to 1.
The angle between the
x1 axis and x2 is 0.
So l2 is 0.
90 degrees cosine of
90 degrees is zero.
l3 would be equal to 0.
So if I put this set of
direction cosines into this
complicated polynomial,
the term l1 squared
sigma 1, 1 stays in.
But l2 is 0.
l3 is 0.
And I've got either an l2 or an
l3 or both in all of these
other terms.
So along the x1 direction, the
only term that stays in is
sigma 1, 1 squared
times l1 squared.
But l1 is unity.
So along the x1 direction the
value of sigma is sigma 1, 1.
And by inference the value of
the property that we would
measure along x2 would
be sigma 2, 2.
And the value of the property
along x3, guess
what, sigma 3, 3.
So in this three by three array
of numbers for sigma ij,
there's a very direct meaning
to the diagonal
values of the tensor.
These are the values that you
would measure along x1, along
x2, and along x3 directly.
So the off diagonal terms are
going to be saying something
about how the extreme values
of the property are aligned
relative to our reference
axes.
OK, any comment or questions
at this point?
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we've defined
those as the cosines of the
angles between the
reference axes.
And this is the direction in
which we're applying our
electric field or our
generalized forced temperature
gradient, concentration
gradient, magnetic field, or
what have you.
OK, I've got some time left.
So let me push this further into
a different form by using
the elements of the tensor to
define a locus in space.
Again, what I'll do is something
that may seem silly.
But we'll see that there are
some very useful and profound
conclusions to be
drawn from it.
Let me take the elements of
the tensor and use them as
coefficients to define
a surface.
I'm going to take sigma 1, 1 and
multiply it by the product
of the coordinate x1 times x1.
What I'm viewing this
now is a variable.
I'm going to take sigma 2,
2 and multiply it by the
coordinate x2 and x2 again.
Sigma 3, 3 and I multiply
that by x3 times x3.
And then I'll have these
cross-terms, sigma 1, 2, x1,
x2, and so on.
Or in short, I'm going
to define a
function sigma ij xi xj.
And xi and xj are running
variables.
x1, x2, x3, they can extend
from 0 to infinity.
But now I'm going to take this
sum of nine terms and I'm
going to set it equal
to a constant.
And what constant could be
neater and cleaner and more
abstract than unity?
But I could say that some
function of x1, x2, x3 equal
to a constant is going to define
a locus of points in
space, which satisfy
that equation.
And we do that all the time.
We specify some functional
relationship that defines in
the space some surface f of
xi xj equals a constant.
And that's done all time
in mathematics.
I've yet to encounter yet a
department of mathematics that
did not have in its corridors
some glass case that was
filled with yellowing plaster
figures, that some of them
cracking or already cracked,
that represented exotic
surfaces, like elliptic
paraboloids and
things of that sort.
I think the last time I walked
down the corridor of building
two there really was one of
those in our mathematics
department in the little door
that opened out onto the great
court about halfway down
that corridor.
But you've seen these things I'm
sure, elliptic cylinders,
elliptic cones, and all sorts
of glorious things.
This function, though, is
a very special one.
This is a quadratic equation
in the second order of
coordinates.
And this is referred to
as a quadratic form.
And sometimes for short, since
that's something of a
mouthful, one refers to
this as a quadric.
And we are going to very shortly
demonstrate that this
particular function tells you
everything you could possibly
want to know about the variation
of a tensor property
with direction, how the
magnitude of the property
changes, how the direction of
the resulting current flow or
flux is oriented.
And this is, consequently,
called, when applied to a
tensor, the representation
quadric.
Because it really does represent
anything you would
like to know about the
physical property.
This will be demonstrated
in short order.
Let's first notice, though, that
there's only a limited
number of surfaces that can be
represented by this equation.
One of them is one
that we're all
familiar with, an ellipsoid.
And that's most easily
represented when we've
referred it to the principal
axes of the ellipsoid.
So an ellipsoid is
a quasi-sausage
like thing like this.
These sections perpendicular
to x3, x1, and x2 are all
ellipsoids.
And if this semi-axis is a and
this semi-axis is b and this
semi-axis is c, the equation of
the surface in that special
orientation is x1 squared over a
squared plus x2 squared over
b squared plus x3 squared
over c squared equals 1.
OK, the surface that
we have defined
involves tensor elements.
And if the equation is ever
going to get into this form,
we've had to get rid of
these cross-terms.
And we are going to have
principal axes that are some
function of the tensor elements
that would be out
here in the form of some
aggregate sigma ij prime.
So we'll have to see how one
could go from a tensor that
describes an ellipsoid in
a general orientation to
something that has been
diagonalized and has the
coordinate system taken along
the principal axes.
But that's only one
possible surface
that we could encounter.
The second one is one that we
might encounter that, when we
put it in diagonal form, has
this form, x1 squared over a
squared plus x2 squared over b
squared minus z squared over c
squared equals 1.
This is something that
has a peculiar shape.
It's sort of an hourglass
like figure.
It has an ellipsoidal
cross-section.
This is x3.
This is x1.
This is x2.
It has an ellipsoidal section
perpendicular to x3.
But it has, as a cross-section
in planes that are parallel to
x3, paraboloids.
And the shape of the paraboloids
depends on which
particular section that
you take through x3.
This is a surface that's
called a hyperboloid.
And it's all one continuous
surface.
So this is called a hyperboloid
of one sheet,
sheet in the sense of surface.
And then down in here when x3
is 0, it would again be an
ellipsoidal cross-section but a
little bit smaller than when
we increase x3 above 0.
OK, and the other surface,
another surface, a third kind
of surface is something that
occurs when the terms in front
of two coordinates are negative,
x2 squared over b
squared x3 squared over
c squared equals 1.
This is something that
looks like two
surfaces nose to nose.
The cross-section of these two
different sheets are ellipsis.
The cross-sections
passing through--
let's see.
This would be the
shape for x1.
That would be the special
direction.
And then this could
be x2 and this x3.
OK, this is called an
hyperboloid of two sheets.
And it has the property that the
distance to the surface in
orientations in between the
asymptotes of these hyperbolic
sections, these radii,
are imaginary.
And between the asymptotes, if
we take a section, we would
have two hyperboloids
in a cross-section.
And again, a range of directions
between the
asymptotes in which the radius
would be imaginary in
directions along the coordinate
which has the
positive sign we'd have
a minimum radius.
And this would get progressively
larger and go to
infinity along the asymptote.
Finally, there's a third
surface in which, by
extension, all three terms
in x1, x2, and x3
have negative signs.
And what does this look like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, it does.
It's something that's called
an imaginary ellipsoid.
So called because the radius in
all direction is imaginary.
And what does it look like?
You just have to use
your imagination.
That's all.
Because it's an imaginary
ellipsoid.
Is that something that we could
ever get if we were
using the elements of
a property tensor?
The answer, he says with
a big wink, yes.
It's unusual but yes.
You can get physical properties
whose magnitude as
a function of direction
do this.
All right, I think that is
a sufficiently formal and
deadening component to our
presentation that it would be
appropriate to take a break
and stretch a little bit.
When we return, I will show
you an amazing connection
between the anisotropy of a
physical property and this
representation surface.
So called because it
tells you how the
property is going to change.